he's an actor producer rapper and
songwriter Newsweek called him the most
powerful actor in Hollywood and Forbes
called him the most bankable star
worldwide he's worth over two hundred
and fifty million dollars
he's Will Smith unhear his top 10 rules
for success don't ever let somebody tell
you you can't do something not even me
all right
you got a dream
you got to protect it
people can't do something themselves
they want to tell you you can't do it
you want something go get it
period we didn't grow up with the sense
that where we were was where we were
going to be you know we grew up with the
sense that where we were almost didn't
matter because we were becoming we were
becoming right something greater there's
a concept that I don't want to be a an
icon I want to be an idea you know I
want to represent an idea i want to
represent possibilities I want to
represent magic right that you're in a
universe in two plus two equals four
two plus two only equals four if you
accept that two plus two equals four
two plus two is going to be what I want
it to be you know and there's that
there's a like there's that there's a
redemptive power that making a choice
has you know rather than feeling like
you're at a fete to all the things that
are happening make a choice like you
just decide what is going to be who
you're going to be how you're going to
do it just decide and then from that
point the universe is going to get out
your way it's like it's water once the
it wants to move and go around stuff you
know so for me I want to represent
possibilities I want to represent the
idea that you really can make what you
want one of my favorite books is the The
Alchemist Paulo Coelho and that's just I
just believe that I believe that I can
create whatever I want to create if I
can put put my head on it right study it
learn the patterns and you know I just I
it's hard to put into words real
metaphysical esoteric nonsense
but I feel very strongly that we are who
we choose to be
the difference between depression and
joy right and I think its purpose right
it's like when you wake up in the
morning and your life means something to
somebody other than you that you have a
purpose if you don't go do the things
that you're going to do people's lives
will suffer and I think that that kind
of purpose that like to live in service
not to you but to live in service to
humanity to live in service to your
family to live in service to your church
to your city to your country to the
world living in service is that I feel
like that is the purest form of joy
greatness is not this wonderful esoteric
illusive godlike feature that only the
special among us are will ever taste you
know it's something that truly exists in
all of us it's very simple this is what
I believe and I'm willing to die for it
yeah period it's that simple I Know Who
I am I don't know what I believe I Know
Who I am I know who what else all I need
to know that's how hard you know so from
there you do what you need to do you
know and I think what happens is we make
the situation more complex than it has
because we're looking for complexities
got to be something complex to
understand it can't be that easy now
the road to success is through
commitment and through the strength to
drive through that commitment when it
gets hard and it is going to get hard
and you're going to want to quit
sometimes but it'll be colored by who
you are and more who you want to be I
definitely found that wanting to be an
actor stems from wanting to be somebody
and wanting to say something to people
the only thing that that I can see and
you can never really look at yourself
the only thing that I see that is
distinctly different about me is I'm not
afraid to die on a treadmill right I
will run it would not be outworked I
will not be be outworked right period
yeah you know you might have more talent
than me you might be smarter than me you
might be sexier than me you might be all
of those things you got it on me in nine
categories but if we get on the
treadmill together right there's two
things you're getting off first or I'm
going to die it's really that simple
right so let's go back to the question
about what if people block me out
there's going to be two options yeah I'm
going to get back in or I'm going to be
dead Yeah right it's like you're not
going to outwork me it's a very is such
a simple basic concept is the the guy
who is willing to hustle the most is
going to be the guy that just gets that
loose ball
you know and got the oh he got the oh
okay he got two oh god he's hustling
grabbed out my dad was going to be out
of bounds but he saved it back in it's
like the commodity that I see the
majority of people who aren't getting
the places they want or aren't achieving
the things that they want in this
business is strictly based on hustle
it's strictly based on being out work is
strictly based on missing crucial
opportunities I say all the time if you
stay ready you ain't got to get ready
the separation of talent and skill is
one of the the the greatest
misunderstood concepts for people who
are trying to excel who have dreams that
want to do things talent you have
naturally skill is only developed by
hours and hours and hours of beating on
your craft there's no easy way around it
no matter how
talented you are your talent is going to
fail you if you're not skilled you know
if you don't study if you don't work
really hard and dedicate yourself to
being better every single day
you'll never be able to communicate with
with people I'm motivated by fear fear
you know
fear of what X fear of fear
I hate being scared to do something I
hate that feeling of the feeling that I
had before I had a meeting with Quincy
Jones because it's really Quincy Jones
and a guy named Benny Medina one of and
Jeff Pollan came with the idea for the
Fresh Prince of bel-air and I hated
being scared you know like that I didn't
want to even take the meeting there were
there were opportunities during when I
first my first year as a rapper Bill
Cosby and the people in The Cosby Show
had seen my music video and called me to
be a character to come right and try out
for the Cosby Show and just every time
it was set up for some reason
I couldn't make it the fear of the fear
I hated I just hated that being scared
to do something and I think what
developed in my in my early days was the
the attitude that I started attacking
things that I was scared you a better
man than me
you happy now you're gonna tell will or
not I'm not gonna do your dirty work for
you fine oh I'll call him from the road
yeah and wanted to do the hell dude
Danijela what's up will hey I'm glad
you're here um some business came up I
got a handle so we're gonna have to put
a our trip on hold you understand yeah
yes that's cool just for a couple of
weeks mmm I understand hit it maybe a
little longer yeah what
whatever look I'll call you next week
and we'll iron out the details okay yeah
yeah it was great seeing you son you too
blue
yeah um
I'm sorry will you know what actually
this works out better for me you know
that is slimmies of summer come to class
we're next nuttin you know the well it's
all right to be angry hey why should I
be mad for saying at least he said
goodbye this time I just wish I hadn't
wasted my money buying a stupid present
I'm sorry I'd you know if there was
something that I hey you know what
you're in good to do know nothing Uncle
Phil hey you know ain't like I'm still 5
years old you know ain't like I'm gonna
be sitting up every night asking my mom
when's daddy coming home you know who
needs him hey he wasn't there to teach
me how to shoot my first basket but I
learned didn't huh hey I got pretty damn
good attitude in I'm fulfilled it got
through my first day without him right I
learned how to drive I learn how to
shave I learn how to fight without him I
had 14 great birthdays without him he
never even sent me a damn card
I need him then and I'll need him now
we'll know you know what Uncle Phil let
me get through college without him I'm
gonna get a great job without him I
married me a beautiful honey and I'm
having a whole bunch of kids I'll be a
better father than he ever was and I
sure as hell don't need him for that cuz
I ain't a damn thing he could ever teach
me about how to love my kids how come
you don't want me man
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Daniel Grantham
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of Will Smith's ten rules
resonates the most with you which one
you like the best leave it in the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching continue to believe and
I'll see you soon